>> Now that we have
a flavor of the projects
we did in the past year,
let's move on to today's agenda.
We're happy to have Samhita here,
who we've partnered with to
plan out this today's session
as also tomorrow's session.
So, what they'll do is they'll
give us an overview of
how social work and AI
can work together and,
more specifically, what's
the plan for this day,
how the NGOs will come
in the next session after
lunch to represent,
and what expectations
we should have
from the rest of this workshop.
>> Good afternoon everyone.
We won't to try to
keep you away from
lunch for too long,
I'll make it brief.
So, we are part of
Samhita social ventures.
I have my two colleagues with me,
Mr. Suyash and Mr. Saurabh,
who I will introduce and
they will be part of
the presentation.
So, how we want to structure
their presentation today is,
we want to talk
about what we do as
Samhita a little bit and
introduce ourselves.
Talk a little bit about
our GoodCSR technology platform,
the need for AI in
the social sector
and then problems as NGOs see it,
because we had been hearing from
the technocrats,
the technical perspectives.
So, social perspective
a little bit and then
how the breakout sessions
and the presentations
will be formatted.
So, Samhita is a
social consulting organization.
So, by social consulting,
I mean we want to maximize
the CSR profits or
the CSR impact so to say,
while helping different types
of stakeholders.
So, our stakeholders are
CSR companies, governments,
NGOs, social enterprises,
and academic institutions.
So, we were found nine years now,
so we were found in 2009.
So far we have our presence in
18 states by different
projects we execute.
We have leveraged, we've
received about 4460 grows of
funds of using
our project management
and research consultancy.
These are some of our corporate
lines who we have of service
in the past and are
currently working with.
These are our partners.
So, they're different foundation,
academic institutions
and we're also working
with a BMGF very closely
now on our Wash platform,
which I'll be
explaining in a bit.
A little bit background
on our leadership.
So Priya is the CEO.
She leads operation at
Suhmita Social Ventures
and is a Economics and
a Public Policy
graduate from Yale.
That's Madhu, handles
our operations and all our
project implementations
with different nonprofits.
A look at our board
members and advisors.
So, essentially, we start
with the CSR consulting
because along the NGO partners
who we all feel and rightly so,
are very good in
their field work,
they know what they want to do,
what has to be done on the field.
But when it comes to
understanding technology or how
to pitch the idea or how to
communicate what problems
they're solving,
they would require some help.
Similarly, on the other side,
the CSR committee guys,
they have a mandate
of two percent
to give towards our CSR funds.
So, usually, when we meet client,
a lot of them are not new ones,
to what exactly they what
to do with the funds.
So, they tell us that, "Hey,
this is my budget and my
core cause areas that
typically education,
health, and maybe
women in parliament.
Now you tell me what to do."
So, we probably have to
draw entire map for them,
plan out their strategy,
what are their missions,
visions are and how they
can maximize their social return.
So, we work on CSR consulting,
hand-in-hand goes with
project management,
the research work we do to make
that happen and
knowledge and capacity
building on both ends for
the NGOs and for the CSR clients.
We also have certain
collaborative platform
for specific needs.
For example, we had
a collaboration with GIF,
where we work to improve
the capacity building
of social enterprises,
to help them make
better insights,
prepare better pitches,
and match them with
the impact investors
in those fields.
The next one was with
the international
financial corporations
which works in clean energy.
So, the idea was that
a lot of rural villages
don't have a supply
of electricity,
to find out alternative
electricity
for supply methods
as solar lanterns
or battery-operated lights and
make them available
to these people.
The most recently,
we were working on
water sanitation and
hygiene with BMGF.
So, this is corporate platform.
Part of this is
a small ethnographic study
and a part of study we
are doing in Chandrapur,
which is a district
in Maharashtra.
So, we want to understand
what are the problems this faces,
because this is
a highly challenging district.
It has water shortage,
it has large amounts of people
who defecate in the open.
So how we can prevent that
and we're calling
on innovators to
work on the problems in
this district because we
feel if we can champion
this district,
we can overcome
the most difficult mile.
Then, we can apply
those solutions,
those innovations to
rest of Maharashtra.
So, that's our aim
for this platform.
Talking about our own
technology platforms
and a lot of technocrats
are here in this room.
So, it's a good CSR
platform where we
bring in all the stakeholders,
that is your NGO CSR
corporate people
and knowledge articles on
one platform, so to say.
So, we have about 3,000 social
organizations registered
on the platform and we have
leveraged 117 draw
funds from that.
So, it's essentially
a marketplace
where NGOs put in
their projects and corporates
putting their funding requirements
and we help them match
them and also help them
with different products.
To talk about more of
the platforms association with
the most correct person
because he has
that technology team.
So, I'll give my mic
to Suyash just to make
a brief quick introduction
about the five NGOs
you're going to
deal with in the problem areas.
So, they are working on
problems areas such
as the mismatch
within organ donation and
the organ demands,
so that is one.
The next people are talking
about how we can improve
outcomes for agriculture farmers
by improving the crop yields.
One talks about neonatal care
and how we can improve and
do a prescriptive analysis of
which babies requires more
in medical intervention.
The other one talks
about improving
education outcomes in
schools and on tobacco,
how to prevent tobacco addiction.
So, that's a quick overview of
the different problems
you're going
to see in the next section.
Over to Mr Suyash.
>> Thank you. Just before
getting into what platform is,
you're then not
getting into details
of that any which
way is for the time,
there are a couple of brochures
kept in there for those
who are interested.
I'm sure some of the NGOs with
which we are working with they
are aware of but anyways.
But I think the purpose
of this platform
is actually how we bring in
the technology for the need
of the ecosystem, that is it.
If you look at
the center, it's 117.
That's probably at
tip of the ocean,
drop of the ocean
of the CSR funding
available in the country,
which is coming in from law.
For that, we require
obviously, scale,
if you want to scale
up that not for we but
for the ecosystem then
how we use the
technology in place.
That's where the GoodCSR
came into an action.
So, basically, we covered
the whole life cycle of a CSR,
I don't get into
the details of that.
But, essentially, it's about
why somebody would like
to do those kinds
of interventions,
be it NGOs or the social
sector guys or the cooperates.
How they want to do that
or before that what
exactly they want to do in
all those things and then
how they want to do that?
Now, in each of these places,
we look at the data is important,
the things about how they
make use of the data rightly,
how they are able to use
that data more effectively,
how they're able
to make that data
transparently and
so on and so forth.
That's where the technology
we are trying to
use it all across.
It goes from the strike and
if I want to use
the business kind of things,
which in the CSR lifecycle way,
they look at the strategy
then the program design,
actually implementation and then
going back to
the actual impactness.
So, if I map back to
the professor, [inaudible]
is we start with actually a
data collection,
help them decide or
tell them this is
where you can do it,
not predict per se but
a little bit of prescription.
What we see is as more and more,
you saw 3,000 NGOs that
are already engaged on
the platform and also
about more than 50 corporates.
As and when more and more
people start coming,
we will be able to make
more insightful prescriptions
and all those kind of things.
Towards the end, also
do an impact analysis
and monitoring and
reporting analysis.
So, that's where
the things helps,
but we are more like
an ecosystem builder kind of
a thing and hence we also
beyond the technology,
just a part of it, we
do a lot of outreach.
We get into these kind of
interventions because we
look at its more
collaboratively building.
In fact, the word Souhita is
actually about collective good.
So, how we are doing it together
kind of thing and that
brings us in this.
In that terms, I think we
keep on doing the surveys,
the research, which is
also going to
knowledge part of it.
So, this is one of
the recent survey that we did
and we can see
it aligned with what
we're trying to do here,
and then what the corporates
as well as the NGOs
are trying to look at is
obviously the fundraising,
the money kind of resources,
their effectiveness
in terms of managing.
But, ultimately, that use of
technology finding the right
implementation partners,
they are also on
the top of the things.
So, technology and in
these days we found yes,
AI is something which is there.
In fact, when we looked also
at specifically to AI what kind
of expectations they are and
these are something as an,
we have five NGOs which are
coming in but this is more
like the broader kind
of an expectations
which are coming.
I just brought in here so that
it is in line with
what we are doing,
so we feel good about
that but maybe we can
look at how we take this
forward and maybe keep accessing
are we actually meeting
those new server
or our ecosystem?
Now, to that end,
I think I'll just leave this
further to Saurabh who will
talk more about
the breakout session and
the day is planned
forward. Thank you.
>> Good afternoon everyone.
Sorry I'm I audible?
>> Yes.
>> So this is an eye chart on
this one but I'll
just put it simply.
What we've done is
we've partnered with
NGOs not to use
PowerPoint to tell
you the bleeding
obvious but to use PPT,
we've repurposed the term PPT.
We've gone ahead and understood
the process of the NGO.
We've understood the practices
that have been followed
in the NGO space,
especially from a data
collection perspective,
especially from a validation
and a structuring perspective.
Then finally, first looked at
possible technology solutions
that can come together.
So, in the second half
of the day,
what we're trying
to do is showcase
what's the problem statement
and where do we see
a probable association of
an advanced technology like
artificial intelligence that
can be looked to my report.
Once this is presented,
so it's more like
a context setting,
you will then break out into
brainstorming sessions,
where we will have
the domain experts more from
the MSRA Lab who will be then
tied into these NGO tables.
Who will understand a little
more in depth of how they
look at data and what
is the availability of
information with them,
what are the challenges and how
they possibly want to use it,
come up with possible use cases
and solutions which
can then be presented in
the first half tomorrow, right?
So, that's the overall agenda
and the framework.